I'm gonna do this slightly differently
to the way most of you dinner I think so
the people who I've seen your answers
right but like you to put this just on
the side maybe parallel to what they've
got just so you can see you can do it a
different way with exactly the same
result but you can make a decision about
which way you think is better okay so
the first thing we should do before we
get any equations written down its
define where's the origin where are we
actually starting okay so I'm actually
going to put hands up if you quit the
origin at the top doing heads up yeah
okay which is fairly sorry which is
fairly intuitive because that's what we
did last time I'm gonna show you that
you can just as equally put the origin
at the street level okay one of the
things that will be nice about that is
that my distances will be positive but
as you'll see in a second it won't
matter all that much but you can be
different places okay so let's say let
the street level
well let the origin sorry be at street
level
X is our displacement budget right now
we were saying before that we're dealing
with the same kind of number for gravity
we're going with 9.8 again sometimes you
get Tim it doesn't really matter if we
say acceleration is equal to minus 9.8
this is something that we always know
it's the same throughout the system okay
we were to graph this then the
acceleration would just be that that
constant okay how am I gonna get from
here to velocity I'm really integrate
right okay now just like before
you get the same kind of function so
you're gonna get you're gonna be writing
this a lot of times okay because many
objects are babies kinds of rules right
but when we working on the cluster here
now we've got something different to
star in the origin and map being at rest
at the beginning right so I would say
but when time equals 0 what's the
velocity well it was given to us as this
speed in the upward direction right
happy with that so now when I'm working
out my constants for T equals minus 9.8
time's your bus
what okay so now I have a value for that
constant which is not zero there's Wasi
okay
now I want to know that'll tell me later
on it'll tell me how long it takes and
what speed it's going right to go to
displacement let's integrate again
okay again because I didn't pick the
origin being up there okay I've got a
nonzero value for my immature condition
some say but X of 0 the value of x when
x is 0 is equal to 100 okay so you can
see again these are gonna cancel out
over you because they all depend on time
so I'm going to get the X being equal to
you happy with that so far yeah okay
now by the way this is the reason why
sometimes as mathematicians we can
conveniently forget unlike physicists
that you know well at 9.8 I can just
sort of mix and match the numbers
because this is an imaginary system so
sometimes you'll see 10 for the express
purpose the exam mark has just wanted to
make this easier to factorize okay
unfortunately for you guys as a
factorization there so you went to
quadratic formula and you should have
gotten to two values for time when
you're trying to solve for this
placement being zero okay so I probably
should've said something before the ball
hits the ground when x equals zero for a
displacement is zero so if you didn't
choose if you chose the on origin to be
up here you would have had to have said
x equals minus 100 right and you would
come out with exactly the same equation
do you see how they're equivalent
so what we're at two values and someone
yet given to me what were the two times
that we got I think it's like minus two
point something well minus 1.9 something
yeah what do we get
are you special okay did someone okay
I'll ask you in a second what what you
did someone solve this what did you get
should have both values you've got to
write down both so didn't know what's
all this way can I have the other one
it's quadratic
two point minus three point zero zero
six becomes zero is one right okay
now this is a point you do actually have
to get from this equation you have to
get both answers even though one is
invalid okay it's a shortcut to just say
I just want the positive values
sometimes you do it if I didn't say that
T equals zero is the t's friends here is
the domain sometimes estimate for
instance T equals zero is it represents
sorry represents topic okay in which
case negative values for T are
meaningful okay - 2.01 I guess would be
like 159 or something like that
okay so you can't just take a shortcut
and not write it down you must have it
there I know in this case we're gonna
discount it by now which is very easier
greater than or equal to okay but please
don't just not write it okay you must
include it all right so therefore I just
have my one day ten point one
okay so what does that tell me what does
that correspond to it means that he
throws it up comes back round and off
the ten point one seven seconds it hits
okay now that is one of the questions
what was the other question how fast is
it going at that time right sir how do I
get back
good I'm gonna take that 10.17 we just
flipped up mm-hmm and I'm gonna bring it
back to ya yeah so velocity is equal to
minus no pigs okay what did you get
Justin places okay so what I'll tell you
does this make sense
what's the - independent means it's
going downward check what is this 59.7
indicate mmm well he throws it up at 40
okay do you remember when we were having
a look at questions like I was story
that man during up and down right when
something's just being acted on by a
constant acceleration if he caught it
again Keynes of the end catches the ball
on its way down okay
just like that it stops there how fast
would it be going if he caught it
exactly where he threw it from answer
exactly the same it's thrown up at 40 it
come back down at 40 but because it ends
up falling an extra hundred meters
that's why it has the opportunity to
pick up a little more speed okay based
on whatever your acceleration so it hits
the ground after 10.17 seconds
traveling at
okay there are many questions that the
process going through sure how did you
get your time yep yep okay yeah you
worked out the downward path okay so
I've with that the same amount of work X
you're way less what okay sure I guess
we want to try and keep the equations we
have as simple as we can to represent
the situation Facebook okay